mademoiselle ce look
vous pouvez poser votre sac il serait
charmante la demoiselle
c'est qui en fait j'étais pions pendant
six ans au collage je vais un jour stade
on va la ferme pédagogique la base il
est clos je passe le concours
d'infirmière
j'ai réussi les créer faut que je leur
âme je suis intéressé par d'autres
services comme la pédiatrie les urgences
pas très bien ce que voulait faire en
fait je dois choisir maintenant et ça
doit pas être facile pendant dix heures
par jour devant un magasin
le seul avantage de mon travail c'est
que tu peux faire du business à chaque
fois que je vais en parler de ses
nombreux
bush
vous les gardez votre place virez le me
suis séparé tu connais des dames on a
grandi dans le même quartier sur ma
gueule je suis ton pote mariaggi toi
c'est la dernière fois que vous avez des
problèmes avec eux au magasin non
c'était pas facile mais je suis
sérieusement tendus tu veux dire c'est
pas bien ce que vous avez fait casse toi
et tu devrais avoir honte
on ne sait jamais ça j'ai besoin que tu
m'expliques j'aime pas qu'ils vont pas
tarder à entrer chez patrick